[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم في الحلقه
الخامسه من تغطيتنا لاحداث العام
2014 نتوقف اليوم مع شهر مايو الذي تميز
بحدث اثنين الاول الانتخابات الرئاسيه
التي شهدتها مصر اواخر الشهر والتطورات
الاخيره التي جرت في الشمال والغرب
الافريقي على خلفيه ازمه مالي وقبل مناقشه
هذين الملفين بتفصيل اكبر نتوقف مع ابرز
ما حمله الشهر من
احداث
يبدا شهر مايو بالمشهد الذي طبع الكثير من
شهور العام
2014 ازمه اوكرانيا حيث النزاع لا يتوقف
وينتقل من مرحله الى اخرى اكثر خطوره
ويتحول الوضع الى حرب اهليه مع بدء قواه
كيف في اليوم الاول هجوما على المناطق
المتمرده المواليه لموسكو في الشرق ويتوسع
القتال من سلافيانسك الى اوديسا على البحر
الاسود
في الهند في هذا البلد وقبيل منتصف الشهر
يعلن عن فوز حزب بهاراتيا جناتا في
الانتخابات البرلمانيه لينهي سيطره حزب
المؤتمر او حزب ال نهرو على السلطه التي
دامت طيله السنوات العش الاخيره وفي معظم
الاوقات منذ استقلال الهند عام
1947 يدعو رئيس الوزراء الجديد راندا مودي
نظيره الباكستاني لحضور حفل تنصيبه
فيستجيب نواش الشريف وتحدث بينهما مصافحه
توصف بالتاريخ وتلوح في الافق بوادر وفاق
في علاقات
البلدين في اليوم الس 16س عشر من هذا
الشهر يعلن اللواء الليبي خليفه حفتر بدء
ما سماها عمليه الكرامه لتدخل ليبيا في
منعطف خطير من عدم الاستقرار السياسي
والعنف الذي لا يزال يتداعى فصولا حتى
الان بعيد منتصف الشهر تلتهب الاوضاع في
قلب القاره الافريقيه فمع تصاعد العنف في
ليبيا تشتعل الاوضاع هذه المره في مالي
مجددا بين قوات الطوارئ والقوات الحكوميه
وترسل فرنسا 3000 جندي اضافي بعد شهور من
تدخلها العسكري في المنطقه التي تشهد
تعقيدات وتشعبات كبيره في العلاقات
والولاءات بين الجماعات المسلحه فيما
بينها من ناحيه وبينها وبين حكومات دول
المنطقه من ناحيه اخرى
وتبرر فرنسا نشر قواتها بانها تريد محاصره
التطرف القادم من ليبيا لكن قرب نهايه
العام تعترف فرنسا بما اكدته من قبل مصادر
عده من خطا وفشل التدخل العسكري ويؤذن ذلك
باطلاق سراح اخر رهائنها في مالي وفق صفقه
مع الجماعات المسلحه في الع من الشهر ينفذ
جيش في تايلاند انقلابا ويعلن الاحكام
العرفيه في انحاء البلاد بعد اشهر من
المواجهات بين الحكومه والمعارضه ويرفض
الاعتراف بانما حدث انقلاب لكنه بعد يومين
فقط يعترف بتنفيذ انقلابه بانقلاب املته
الضروره كما يقول قبل نهايه الشهر بايام
قليله تجري انتخابات الرئاسه في مصر وسط
اقبال ضعيف على التصويت اضطر لجنه
الانتخابات الى تمديدها ليوم ثالث واعلان
ذلك اليوم عطله
رسميه
كان ارضهم رغم اجواء التوتر السياسي الحاد
التي سيطرت على مصر قبيل الانتخابات
الرئاسيه بدت نتيجه تلك الانتخابات لطرفي
الصراع محسوبه من قبل ان تبدا فالحظوظ
كلها تصب لمصلحه المرشح الاقوى عبد الفتاح
السيسي وزير الدفاع الذي استقال من منصبه
ليتمكن من الترشح للرئاسه كمدني اما عن
كون تلك الانتخابات محسومه النتيجه فهذا
ما اكده واقع الحال في مصر فالسيسي حظي
بدعم من القوى التي اوصلته للسلطه وهي
خليط من مؤسسات مهيمنه كالجيش والشرطه
والقضاء والاعلام وقوى دينيه كالازهار
والكنيسه واحزاب سياسيه تجمع بين تلك التي
ازدهرت في عهد الرئيس المخلوع حسني مبارك
وحزب النور الذي يمثل قطاعا من السلفيين
في مصر في المقابل فان صباح الذي عده
انصاره مرشح الثوره بدا في وضع لا يحصد
عليه فحتى التيار الناصيري الذي ينتمي الى
اليه ويعد من ابرز رموزه القى بثقله الى
جانب السيسي ولم يتبقى حول صباحي الا عدد
من الشباب وحركات محدوده التاثير مثل
الاشتراكيين الثوريين وغيرهم وقاطعت القوى
الرافضه للانقلاب وفي مقدمتها جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين
الانتخابات ومع كل هذا الفارق في موازين
القوى
فالمرشد الى الشارع ولا يختلط بالناس
بدعوى المخاوف الامنيه بل ولا يهتم حتى
بتقديم برنامج انتخابي واضح لكن الاعلام
يتعامل مع كل ذلك على انه امر طبيعي وربما
المنطق
بعينه جاء اليوم الموعود لانتخابات
الرئاسه التي حدد ال 26ش وال 27 من مايو
موعدا لها يومها وقعت المفاجاه وشهد عليها
الانصار قبل الخصوم ضعف واضح في الاقبال
على التصويت هدد الناخب المصري بان ثمت
قانونا يلزم كل من يتخلف عن التصويت بدفع
غرامه ماليه اطلقت نداءات من ماذن المساجد
تستحث الناخبين وتذكرهم بفضل التصويت
واهميته غاب الشباب تماما ولم ترصد
كاميرات الاعلام الموالي سوى مجموعات من
النساء وكبار السن على الرغم من تمديد
فتره التصويت ليوم ثالث عاد الحديث مجددا
عن اقبال الناخبين على التصويت رغم عدم
تغير مشهد صور اللجان الخاليه تمهيدا
لاعلان النتائج النهائيه فاز السيسي
وبنسبه عاليه من الاصوات تجاوزت 95% على
منافسه حمدين صباحي وفي الثامن من يونيو
ادى عبد الفتاح السيسي اليمين الدستوريه
رئيسا لمصر لولايه مدتها اربع سنوات امام
الجمعيه العموميه للمحكمه الدستوريه حضر
مراسم اداء اليمين الرئيس المؤقت عدلي
منصور الذي تولى هذا المنصب بصفته رئيسا
للمحكمه الدستوريه العليا بموجب خريطه
الطريق والذي عاد الى موقعه السابق في
المحكمه الدستوريه فور تنصيب السيسي كما
حضر اداء اليمين الدستوريه الباب توادرس
الثثاني بطرق الكنيسه القبطيه وامام
الازهر الشيخ احمد الطيب ورئيس الوزراء
ابراهيم محلب واعضاء حكومته اقسم بالله
العظيم ان احافظ مخلصا على النظام
الجمهوري وان احترم الدستور والقانون وان
ارعى مصالح الشعب رعايه
كامله وبعد انتهاء مراسم اداء اليمين عقد
حفل استقبال في قصر الاتحاديه الرئاسي
بحضور ممثلي دول عربيه وغربيه وافريقيه تم
خلالها توقيع وث رسميه لتسليم السلطه الى
الرئيس
الجديد ليس بعيدا من مصر وبينما كان
السيسي يستعد لتسلم الرئاسه رسميا عاد
اللواء الليبي خليفه حفتر للظهور على
الساحه ليعلن بد ما سماها عمليه الكرامه
قاد اللواء الذي ينسب اليه لقب المتقاعد
عمليه عسكريه ضد الجماعات التي قادت
الثوره الليبيه ضد القذافي ويصفها هو
بالارهاب من دون ان يكشف عن الجهه التي
كلفته بهذه العمليه بدات العمليه بمدينه
بنغازي منتصف مايو لكنها توسعت لاحقا
لتشمل اجزاء اخرى من البلاد وبعد اشهر من
انطلاقها اعلن الجيش الليبي النظامي
تاييده للعمليه لمواجهه الميليشيات في
مدينه بنغازي مثل ميليشيا انصار الشريعه
كما اعلن ضباط القوات الجويه في مدينه
طبرق انضمامهم لها وانضم اليها ايضا انصار
اخرون منهم رئيس الوزراء الليبي السابق
علي زيدان وسفير لدى الامم المتحده
وقطاعات امنيه اخرى وفي المقابل رفضها
اعضاء المؤتمر الوطني العام في طرابلس
وحزب العداله والبناء وجماعه الاخوان
المسلمين والميليشيات الاسلاميه مثل غرفه
عمليات ثوار ليبيا وشهداء الساب عش من
فبراير وتنظيم انصار الشريعه وهكذا تدخل
ليبيا في نفق مظلم من العنف المتواصل حتى
يوم الناس
هذا ولا تتوقف دائره العنف عند الحدود
ليبيا فبتن مع عمليه حفتر تعلن فرنسا نشر
3000 جندي في محيط ليبيا وتساعد قوات
الحكومه الماليه في احتواء تمرد الطوارق
في كيدال تحت شعار مكافحه الارهاب في
اشاره الى حركه الازواد وحركات جهاديه
اخرى كانت اختطفت رعايا فرنسيين وتودع
مالي العام بصفقه يتم بها تحرير اخر معتقل
الفرنسي لدى المسلحين فيما تتبدد ملامح
الازمه بين الاشتعال احيانا وال خفوت
احيانا
[تصفيق]
اخرى انه سيرج لازار فيتش الذي امضى ثلاثه
اعوام مع خاطفيه اطلاق سراحه اغلق ملف
المختطفين الفرنسيين في مالي شكليا تفادت
فرنسا حرج دفع فديه للخاطفين
الا ان تسريبات منظمات غير حكوميه تؤكد ان
ثمن ذلك كان الافراج عن عدد من الجهاديين
المسجونين في
مالي يشكل استمرار الوجود الفرنسي في مالي
وبدولة طوارق الازواد والجماعات الجهاديه
الى الاسراع بانقاذ باماكو بحسب رؤيته
وانتشال الحكومه الضعيفه من براثن هذه
الجماعات في مايو الماضي اعلن رئيس
الوزراء المالي موسى مارا الحرب على
متمردي الطوارق الذين استهدفوه باطلاق
النار لدى زيارته كيدال بعد ان اختطفوا
عددا من الموظفين
الحكوميين واندلعت مواجهات مسلحه انتهت
بهزيمه قوات الحكوميه ومقتل العشرات منها
وقد تغير وجه العمليه العسكريه بمالي في
اغسطس الماضي بتغيير فرنسا تسميه عمليه
مكافحه الارهاب في البلاد من سيرفال الى
برخان فالعمل التي كانت مقصوره على القوات
الفرنسيه في مالي توسعت لتشمل الشراكه مع
دول الساحل الافريقي ممثله في موريتانيا
ومالي وتشاد والنيجر وبوركينافاسو
القوه التي قوامها 3000 دي فرنسي تسعى
لكبح جماح المتمردين والجهاديين في ان
واحد لكن الهدف الاسمى لها هو حمايه
المصالح الفرنسيه وفي مقدمتها حقول
اليورانيوم التي تغذي المفاعلات النوويه
الفرنسيه الى جانب القوات الفرنسيه هناك
ايضا بعثه الامم المتحده متعدده الابعاد
لتحقيق الاستقرار في مالي والتي يتجاوز
تعدادها 12 الفا وهي مكلفه بالعمل على
استتب با الامن في شمال مالي والعمل على
عدم عوده المسلحين اليها كما ترعى البعثه
جولات المفاوضات بين اطراف الازمه في مالي
والتي تجري اغلبها في الجاره
الجزائر وقد جددت الامم المتحده مهمه
البعثه لغايه يونيو المقبل في انتظار ما
سيسفر عنه غبار المفاوضات من
تفاهمات موضوع التطورات التي شهدتها دوله
بالي في العام
2014 يتها على المشهد محليا وافريقيا
نراجعه مع ضيفنا من وشط عبد الله ماما
دوبا الخبير في الشؤون الافريقيه اهلا بك
سيد عبد الله بعد سبعه اشهر تقريبا من
انطلاق واشتعال الازمه في مالي ما الذي
بقي من هذه الازمه وما الذي تم تجاوزه
برايك شكرا على الاستضافه اعتقد بان
الازمه الماليه لما تراوح مكانها بعد نظرا
لتعطل المباحثات التي حدثت التي تحدث
حاليا في الجزائر اذا اجريت حتى الان اربع
جولات وحتى الان لم يتم التوصل الى اتفاق
النهائي وما لم يتم التوصل الى هذا
الاتفاق النهائي اعتقد بان الوضع يبقى على
حاله اي بان هناك قوات تحالف دولي مسانده
للجيش المالي ترابط على تخوم المناطق
الشماليه خاصه في منطقه جاو وتمبكتو في
حين ان المنطقه
الشماليه ماليه ما زالت تحت سيطره الحركات
التي تطالب بالانفصال وهي حركه الحركه
الوطنيه لتحرير اواد امنلا والمجلس الاعلى
لتحرير ازواد
وا الجناح من الحركه العربيه لتحرير اواد
وبالتالي اضافه الى الى تواجد بعض
المجموعات الجهاديه وان كان وجودها ما
زال يعني ما زال البعض يتحدث عنه لكنه ليس
مرئيا على على الارض الا في حاله القيام
بعمليات بدات فعل تلك الحركات تنفيذ بعض
منها منذ اكثر من ثلاثه
اشهر الوضع ماز بالافراج عن الرهينه
الفرنسي ماذا عن دور فرنسا فيما يتعلق
بالازمه في مالي بتطورها منذ انطلاق
الازمه واشتعال الحرب وانتهاء بالافراج عن
الرهين الفرنسي كيف تابعت الدور الفرنسي
فيما يتعلق بالازمه في مالي
اعتقد بان فرنسا انطلقت في شهر يناير 2013
من عمليه سيرفال من
اجل كبح تقدم الوحدات المحسوبه على
الحركات الجهاديه وعلى الحركه الوطنيه
لتحرير ازواد نحو الجنوب المالي بعد ان
حررت مناطق تمبكتو وجاو توقفت دون كيدال
تاركه ما كانت تعتبره فرصه للاطراف في
الدخول في محاورات في حوارات وفي نقاشات
مباشره من اجل التوصل الى صيغه تنهي
الازمه ولكنها تحولت العمليه من عمليه من
عمليه ميدانيه ل للحفاظ على ما يسمونه
بالوحده الترابيه لارض مالي الى عمليه
اشمل واوسع من اجل محاربه الارهاب تحولت
من عمليه سرفال اذا الى عمليه برخان لتشمل
كل منطقه الساحل بصوره بصوره عامه باطار
استراتيجيه تجمع بين موريتانيا و
موريتانيا ومالي وبوركينا فاسو والنيجر
ومع ذلك ما زال الوضع لم يعد الى الى سابق
عهده بالتوازن بالتوازي مع مفاوضات
الجزائر التي بالاشاره الى مفاوضات
الجزائر سيد عبد الله هل تتوقع ان يشهد
هذا الملف انفراجا في العام
2015 نتمنى نتمنى نحن في المنطقه في ان
يتم التوصل الى الى انفراج سريع في الوضع
في مالي ولكن اعتقد بانه من الصعب ان يتم
التوصل الى الى مثل هذا الانفراج اذا لم
تتفق الاطراف على خارطه طريق واضحه لان
تباين ما زال كبيرا جدا في حين الحكومه
الماليه ترفض السماع بالحديث عن ايه نوع
من الحكم الذاتي اومن الاستقلال الذاتي
لمناطق الشمال تصر كبريات الحركات خاصه
الحركه الوطنيه لتحرير اواد والمجلس
الاعلى زواد وجناح من الحركه العربيه لت
تحرير الزواد الى الى شبه ما هو الى
فيدراليه موسعه وبالتالي اعتقد بان الوسيط
الجزائري اقترح على ال اقترح على ال على
الطرفين صيغه يمكن من خلالها ان
اي ينعم سكان الشمال ب حريه موسعه من اجل
تسير تسير الاقليم بانتخاب الولات وبتحويل
37% من موارد الدوله الماليه الى مناطق
الشمال ولكن حتى الان ما زالت الاطراف تصر
كل يصر على موقف
ماذا عن دور الازمه في مالي في التاثير في
دول الجوار وتاثرها هي بما يجري في
الجوار اكيد بان الوضع في
مالي اثر بشكل كبير على الوضع العام
لمنطقه الساحل بصوره منطقه الساحل بصوره
عامه اي ان عدم الاستقرار في مالي يؤثر
مباشره على دول كموريتانيا و كالجزائر
وبوركينا فاسو اضافه الى ذلك تفاقم الوضع
بعد انهيار النظام النظام الرئيس الليبي
الراحل معمر القذافي وبالتالي اعتقد بان
مالي تشكل اليوم بؤره تؤرق كافه دول دول
المنطقه ولذلك تسعى كل من جهتها الى ان ان
ان يتم التوصل الى صيغه سياسيه نهائيه
تنهي الازمه وتجعل الدول في مواجهه تحديات
تحديات التنميه ومن الاكيد بانه بغياب اي
استقرار في شمال مالي لا يمكن لاي دوله من
دول الجوار ان تنعم بمثل هذا الاستقرار
عبد الله ماما دوبا الخبير في الشؤون
الافريقيه كنت معنا من وشط شكرا جزيلا
لك نختم من تايلاند التي شهدت في الشهر
نفسه انقلابا عسكريا رفض الجيش الاعتراف
به بدايه لكنه عاد وقال انه قام به بحكم
الضروره بعد اشهر من احتجاجات للمعارضه
راى كثيرون انها كانت لم تكن مبرره نتوقف
مع اهم المشاهد من انقلاب تايلاند وما
سبقه من تطورات
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
.
ow 2 .
مشاهدينا الى هنا ينتهي استعراضنا لابرز
احداث شهر مايو من هذا العام العام 2014
في الغد نتوقف مع احداث شهر يونيو ويسعدني
ان اكون معكم فيه مره اخرى الى اللقاء
باذن
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الله
k